my name is will creighton and i'm a phd
student at stanford i do research about
using cognitive science to make better
tools for programmers and as a part of
that research i think a lot about the
tools that we use and the languages that
we develop in
and how that shapes the way that we
program
and today one of the most foundational
concepts in programming is the api or
application programming interface
because programming today is about
weaving together dozens of tools and
languages and libraries all written by
other people
and the api defines how you work with
these tools
and so api design is a really critical
problem
now i've personally been programming for
about 15 years and i've seen a lot of
apis in that time apis in
object-oriented languages functional
languages systems languages and
dynamically typed and statically typed
contexts
and so when i picked up rust about seven
years ago i found that rus apis were
this really interesting fusion of ideas
from all of these different languages as
well as totally new ones that i'd never
seen before
and so my goal in this talk is to
synthesize some observations about what
makes api design in rus different from
other languages
so rust if you're not familiar is a
relatively new language for systems
programming it fills the same niche as c
plus
and rust has this really powerful type
system that's used to make programs
safer so for example it is much harder
to have a null pointer dereference in
rust than in c plus plus
but rust also has a very different
flavor of software architecture so for
example it doesn't have a concept of
classes or inheritance and instead the
core mechanism for organizing apis is
the trait
and that's where we're going to focus
today
so the way this talk is going to go i'm
going to create a rust api for you live
on stage
and my goal is that in the process of
iterating on this api you can really see
how each construct of the language is
used to accomplish some aspect of api
design and also by live coding it'll
pace the talk a little bit so even if
you don't know that much rust or none at
all you can still keep up and understand
what's going on so let's get started
all right the example we're going to use
today comes from some of my travails in
python a common issue i have
is let's say i have a long running for
loop so from time import sleep for and
in range 100
sleep for one second
when i'm running this for loop i have no
idea how long it's taken or how far i'm
in how far i have left to go and that's
a very frustrating experience
so one of my favorite utilities is
called tqdm
all i have to do is say 4n in tqdm range
100
sleep for one
and then i get this awesome progress bar
that shows me a nice visual
representation the percentage through
the number of iterations how far i have
left to go and this is just a
stupendously handy little utility and
it's a quite nice api all i have to do
is wrap the iterable thing the range and
then otherwise leave my code unchanged
and i get this nice little progress bar
some other nice things about this api
are that it works with other kinds of
iterable objects so for example let's
say i have the count iterator which goes
from 0 to infinity and i say 4n in tqdm
count
sleep 1
then i still get some measure of
progress it doesn't have a bar because
this is an unbounded iterator there's no
technical end to this but it still tells
me at least for example the number of
iterations which is quite nice
however it's a python api and so it has
some drawbacks for example if you use
this in an ill-typed way like 4n in tqdm
of one
then i'll get a runtime type error once
i execute this code saying that int
object is not iterable and i can only
see that error once this actually
executes but at least i get an error
sometimes there are things that are a
little bit more subtle so if i say 4n in
tqdm
range 100 comma bar
format equals bar
and then sleep for one second
then this changes the visual display of
the bar so now i just see the bar and
nothing else if i'm a minimalist and
that's all that i need out of my
progress bar
but what happens if we try this with the
other iterator so i replace range
with count
i don't see anything and that's very
confusing to me as a user to call this
api
and then just observe nothing happening
i'm wondering is this broken is it
hanging what have i done and the answer
is that
bar doesn't exist for these unbounded
iterators it just doesn't display
anything in this case and so this is a
really common issue in api design you
have a combination of options that don't
make sense together that each one
individually makes sense it's nice to
work for unbounded iterators it's nice
to customize my bar format but if i use
them in the wrong way i get not even an
error but just something that seems to
not work
and so these are examples of both good
and bad things that arise in api design
within python and we're going to design
a progress bar in rust and see how we
can address some of these issues along
the way
so let's get to rust
first we need a rust project cargo new
progress
we will open up
the
temp slash progress source main
so this is going to be our
main
and then i'll keep the console over on
the right
where if i say cargo run dash cue i'll
get out but hello world so the default
application is a single file that
contains a function main the entry point
to the application that just prints out
hello world
so
when i start designing apis i like to
begin with a very concrete example of
the functionality that i want and then
generalize that so let's do that
first we need a vector v
one two three
then we need a for loop for n in v dot
itter and then we'll have some kind of
expensive calculation of n
so we need to define that function
function expensive
calculation and that's just going to
take as input a pointer to a 32-bit
integer i32 and it won't do anything
with it it'll just sleep so we'll add
some imports
duration
thread
sleep
and then we will sleep
for one second
so now if i run this
we wait for three seconds
and then the program completes so we
have a basic example of a long running
for loop and now we want to add some
kind of a progress bar
so it won't be as fancy as tqdm but
it'll be nice enough so we'll say let
mute i is equal to zero this is the
state of the progress bar the number of
iterations mute means that we can change
the value of i
and then we'll print out
uh star repeated i times
uh so
and then we'll increment i by one
so if we run this
we'll get nothing one star two stars
and we'll start i one because that at
least gives us one star to begin with i
think that makes a little more sense
and now we have a basic progress bar but
it's kind of ugly it like puts the
things on a new line so we can do a
little bit of a hack here let me just
copy my mystic string from my sticky
note since i didn't want to commit this
to memory clear and string equals this
ansi terminal escape code
don't worry about it not important to
the talk
but now if i run this i get a nice
little progress bar
cool
so this is the start of the
functionality of our api but it's not an
api yet this is a very concrete piece of
code so what i like to do is look at
things in this api that are not
essential to the way that it works
so for example the choice of vector v
shouldn't be just one two and three we
should be able to work for any vector so
we can make a function fun progress
takes a vector v of i-32s
we'll take this code down here
copy it up here
and then add the function call
so each time we change the code we're
not changing the functionality or the
sort of observable behavior just
changing the way that a user would call
into this functionality
and now i want you to take a look at
this progress function and just think to
yourself for a second what are other
aspects of this api they're not
essential to the progress bar
i realize it's after lunch so we'll try
and wake everybody up a bit
okay so one thing is the type of
elements of this vector so a progress
bar should of course work for vectors of
strings as well as vectors of numbers or
other types so we can generalize that by
adding a type parameter so progress of t
so t capital t is a type
and then this takes us input any vector
of type t
so if we try and compile this what
happens
we get an error mismatched types
expected when we called expensive
calculation a pointer to a number but we
got a pointer to a random type so this
correctly caught the error that we need
to simultaneously generalize the
function that we're calling inside of
here along with the parameter of the
vector now one cool thing to note here
for those of you who know more c plus
plus if you try to do this with
templates in c plus plus you would only
get this kind of error when somebody
actually calls the function a big
difference with generics and rust and
other languages that support this
similarly is the
definition of the function is what gets
type checked and if that patch is type
checking it'll always be fine whenever
you call it which is a nice handy
feature to have especially from an api
perspective so the client never has to
deal with like weird type checking
errors that they use your api
incorrectly like that
so we'll make this a function parameter
f is a function from pointers to t to
nothing
then take this
and add it down here
and then we'll run this again
back where we started with a functioning
progress bar and with a little higher
order function
now still we can keep generalizing the
choice of vector here doesn't seem quite
right this should work for anything we
can put into a for loop for instance
let's say i have a hash set h equals
hash set new which we will need to
import
and then we insert an element in there
and what we want to do is call progress
of h and then again run our expensive
calculation
but what's common between a vector and a
hash set what does it mean for something
to be put into a for loop well this is
where traits come into play
so i'm going to go to google
and search for rust
iterator
click on the first result
and in the standard library
documentation we see what we need so
this is a trait
traits in rust are a lot like interfaces
in other languages they define a set of
requirements that a type should
implement and so the iterator trait
defines what makes things iterable such
that you can put them into a for loop
and the requirements of the iterator
trait in rust are these two things
first we have this function
next the way that this works i'll show
you the example in the documentation
you have an array a with elements one
two and three then you can create an
iterator on that array by calling a dot
iter and that itself is immutable
structure and then each time we call dot
next we get out a pointer to one then a
pointer to two and then a pointer to
three and that is wrapped in sum if we
get back an item and it's wrapped or we
get a none if we've reached the end of
the stream
so that's the behavior of an iterator in
rust and the way we formalize that at
the type system level is that function
next takes as input a mutable pointer to
self excuse me which is the object that
implements this trait
and then it returns option so summer
none of self colon colon item
and that is a reference to this thing up
here the associated type which is the
type of elements being iterated over so
if you have this array here one two and
three then the type of elements coming
from this iterator are pointers to
numbers
and generally if you have a vac of t you
get a pointer two t's is what comes out
of your iterator
no this is a little bit different if you
have an iterable interface in other
languages usually this type might be
like a parameter to the iter to the
interface or something like that so this
is one of the more subtle parts of
traits and rust but the main thing is
just it's another part of the interface
it's another requirement that an
iterator has to declare what the type of
this item is
so the way we can use this going back to
our code
is to add another type parameter so
progress now takes an iter type
and that's going to be the first
argument iter of type iter
but in order to put this into a for loop
we need to be able to say
what makes this iterable and we do that
with a where clause where
it the type capital i itter implements
iterator
and we also want to constrain that the
thing that comes out of this iterator is
an item of type t
and now this function just takes type t
so
what with this now we can change our
progress call from v to v dot itter
because a vector itself is not iterable
but an iterator on a vector is and the
same thing for the hash set
we'll run this
and we should see two progress bars one
for the first vector and then one for
the hash set
awesome so we've used the concept of a
trait and a type parameter that is
bounded on the trait with this where
clause to make this progress function
generic over all kinds of things that
are iterable
and this is actually a little too
verbose we can get rid of this parameter
t
and just say that this function takes as
input either colon colon item i think
that's a cleaner and clearer way to
describe what's going on here and again
the program type checks and runs exactly
the same way
so this is pretty good we have a
decently generic api
but it's kind of gross still like this
higher order function thing it's very
you know intrusive i would say i liked
the tqdm style where you just wrapped
the iterable and everything else was
left unchanged so we're going to move to
that style of api which requires a bit
more of a change we need
what we want is something like this 4n
in progress
new of v.iter
then we call the expensive calculation
so we this is what we want how are we
going to get there
let's delete the rest of the example
code
we need some data structure that
represents this iterator so we'll make a
new struct progress
that contains the iterator that it's
given as a type parameter
so iter of type iter and then the state
of the iterator i of type u size which
is an unsigned integer where the number
of bits depends on your architecture
it's an unwieldy name but that's what
they picked
and then we need two things for this
progress data type first is a
constructor like the colon nu and then
something that defines this as an
iterator so we'll say impul
iter progress error
pub function new takes as input a
concrete iterator of type capital i iter
returns self
and that object is progress of iter
comma i colon
zero
okay there's a lot of new syntax here so
let's walk through this
the imple block is a really key concept
it associates a method with a type
so this function new is now associated
with the type progress iter
it's a static method because it doesn't
take self as input and so the way that
we call it is with the double colon
progress colon colon nu
another thing is that this simple block
is quantified so we say for all types
iter
implement
progress of iter so that means anything
we could put here is now a valid call to
this particular progress
and lastly this function new
the capital s self type means whatever
is being implemented so it's just
progress of iter and because rust has a
functional flavor we don't need to use a
return keyword we could just put an
expression and that's returned directly
from the function
so a lot of syntax but it makes the code
a little bit shorter
and next we need to turn this progress
structure into an iterator so we'll say
impul iter iterator
for
progress evitter
and then we also need this bound where
iter
is an iterator
this needs two things a type item and a
function next going from mute self
to option
of self item these are just the
requirements of the iterator interface
and the default behavior of our progress
bar is just to pass items along it
doesn't change them so we can call
self.iter.next
but before we do that we want to display
the state of the iterator so i will
again copy this code up here
and this time we will replace i with
self.i because we have a data structure
that represents the state
and lastly the type item
is whatever's returned from the inner
iterator so we'll say iter colon colon
item
again this is a fair amount of syntax
but what's going on here is we are
implementing a trait for a type so now
the compiler understands that the
progress data structure is an iterator
and can be given to a for loop
and we have to satisfy the requirements
of the interface which are this type
item and a function next that doesn't do
much but just really copy over the code
we were doing before with a little bit
of glue
and now we get rid of this
we have once again no change to the
behavior of our code but still a much
nicer api in my perspective and that's
really the essentials of traits you
define an interface you use these impul
blocks to
either directly attach a method to a
type like new or to implement a trait
for a type so it can be used in certain
ways
all right we're at about the halfway
point in the mark and i think these are
the essentials but now i'm going to dive
deep into some more advanced use cases
for type driven api design and how we
can use traits in some more creative
ways because this is similar to tqdm i
would say this has a pretty similar
flavor minus some of the features
but
for the first thing i want to show you
is i don't like this style of api that's
very inside out you you have v dot itter
and then progress new and so the flow of
control goes from the innermost argument
to all the functions you wrap it with
there's a reason why we have the dot
operator or the pipe operator or all
these things where the left to right
reading order of the code matches the
control flow the execution order of that
code and so what i'd like to do is write
this v
dot itter dot progress
now think for a second about how you
might implement this in any other
programming language
v.iter
the type of iterators over vectors or
hash sets or whatever is a type
implemented in the standard library
i don't own it i can't call up the rest
developers and ask them to implement
that method and just toss it in the
standard library that'll take a little
bit of time more than we have here
and in general when you have a
class-based system it is very hard to
extend types that you don't own
and so you have wrappers and adapters
and all this really ugly crud that's
needed to compose cleanly with existing
code
but
in rust with traits it actually becomes
possible i'll show you how it's like
this i make a new trait progress
iterator extension
that takes a function or that requires a
function progress that takes an iterator
and returns progress of that iterator
then we will implement
for all iterators progress iterator
extension
ext is just a convention in rust for
iter
function progress self arrow capital p
progress itself
and this won't do anything complicated
it's just calling the constructor
but that's it
oh it's almost it you actually have to
add this sized bound which is a bit of a
small memory thing it's not super
critical for this talk but now it's
actually it
that's pretty cool
i just attached a method to a type that
i don't own so that's one basic use case
for traits and rust is these imple
blocks are a lot more powerful than at
first glance and let's actually take a
really close look at this line
it says for all types iter
implement the trait progress iterator
extension
for that quantified type so i
me on this stage i just single-handedly
added a method to every single type in
the rust universe that has ever existed
or will ever exist you don't believe me
i can say
watch this let x equals one dot progress
let y equals blah.progress
all of these are valid well-typed calls
that are unused warnings but it's
actually a well-typed program
now okay you're probably this point
thinking that doesn't seem sane at all
and you you will get an error if you try
and iterate over these things so if i
say 4 blah in y
or x
then
i will get an error
expand this out
that says
in this very large blob of text
essentially that a number is not
iterable and therefore you can't do that
oh yeah an integer is not an iterator
that's the text up here
but the cool thing here is that you have
the capacity to extend all of these
types with new methods if you want and
that allows you to get this really
seamless dot based notation and for
those of you who are sweating a little
bit you're like oh my god i don't want
people randomly attaching methods to my
types that sounds terrifying there are
ways of controlling this within the
language so for example a user has to
import this trait into their module in
order to access this method it's not
just there by default and also you can't
directly attach methods to uh types that
you don't own you have to do it through
traits and there are methods for
resolving ambiguities and stuff like
that there are details that i'm not
covering but the high level up point is
that the trait combined with this simple
block allows you to do this by attaching
these methods and if you might say i
want to disallow one dot progress you
shouldn't be able to do this on types
that aren't iterable then you could add
a where clause you could say where iter
is an iterator and that would disable
the the
this would only attach this method to
iterable types that's probably what i
would do in progress but just as more
text for the purposes of this
demonstration so i won't do that
all right
so that's pretty neat that's cool thing
number one cool thing number two is i
want to talk about how we deal with
splits in the api you know a common
issue is i have for example for
iterators sometimes i have iterators
that are bounded i know how long they
are i know this vector has three
elements and so i want to draw a
progress bar with bounds on it but
sometimes they're unbounded so in rust
that would look like four
n in zero dot dot the iterator from zero
to infinity dot progress
also doing our expensive calculation
so one of these iterators is bounded and
one is not and we want to have different
functionality in both cases
how do we accomplish this in the rust
type system
well first we need to understand how
does rust represent the concept of an
iterator that may or may not have a
length
we go back and there's a trait for that
exact size iterator
so exact size iterator let's read
through this definition
first it requires that anything that
implements this trait must also
implement iterator that's what this
little colon means
so this might seem a little bit like
inheritance it should remind you of
inheritance because you're saying
anything that this like this is like a
class that extends the iterator super
class
but the big difference and the you know
what's different from traditional
object-oriented languages is you are
inheriting a specification
a set of requirements you are not
inheriting an implementation of methods
and so you don't have to have any
convoluted runtime mechanisms for
following an inheritance chain or worse
linearizing a multiple inheritance chain
or any complicated dynamic dispatch so
you just
it's always clear at the time you
compile the code which method you're
referring to if you say dot call a
method
instead you use an inheritance style
thing solely to express requirements
and that ends up i think being a lot
cleaner in practice
and so the idea here is an exact size
iterator is an iterator that also has
these two methods where the relevant one
is function length that tells us the
length of this iterator
so let's implement that first we need
something that represents the
possibility of having a bound so bound
is option of u size where option is some
are none and by default this will be
none we'll assume by default we have an
unbounded iterator
and then we want to implement a method
progress iter
in the case where iter is an exact size
iterator
we'll have pub function with bound that
takes the immutable
owned version of the iterator returns
self this is kind of like a factory feel
self dot
bound equals some
self dot
iter.len
and then return self
so what this impul block is doing is
it's saying
add this method to the progress data
structure but again this is the
power of the impul block only add this
method where the type on the inside
implements a trait
so you can only call with bound when
you're iterating over something that has
a bound and hence we are allowed to
access the dot len function inside of
the implementation of with bound
then we need to have something that
prints out the bounds so we'll make a
quick display so match self.bound
this is a match expression if we have a
bound then we're going to
print out
uh
little brackets and then we'll do some
fun
we'll repeat this self.i times and then
we'll add a space for bound minus self.i
times
and then if we don't have the bound
we will print out exactly what we had
before
except i'm going to move this clear
logic up to the top
so now we get that shared between both
of the iterators
all right
and this is almost a syntax error good
so now if we compile this
we are back at the same place we were
before
let me get rid of this one up here if we
iterate over the vector and say dot
progress dot with bound
then now we have our nice little bounce
star star star
and importantly
to my point oh thank you to my point
about catching helping api clients catch
mistakes
if you try and call that on an unbounded
iterator so if i say dot progress dot
with bound
where this is over the dot dot
which doesn't have a bound
and then i try and compile this
i will get a nice big error uh which
starts with the method with bound exists
for struct progress
but its trait bounds were not satisfied
and read
down range from doesn't implement exact
size iterator that was the bound that
wasn't specified
so that's pretty cool we've now used the
type system to help the user catch an
error this is a method they can only
call in certain cases and the error
message albeit a little bit verbose does
ultimately tell us why this is the case
that the iterator doesn't implement this
certain iterator
now as we're getting into more and more
advanced territory huge caveat this
still isn't a great error message
there's a lot of text in here that takes
someone time to parse through and a big
issue with type driven api design is you
rely on the compiler's generic error
messaging system to help users
understand their mistakes it will catch
their mistakes but it's often up to the
user with the error message to
understand them and that is in itself
often quite a challenge especially when
error messages fall off a cliff in
certain more advanced use cases so
that's a trade-off that you as the
designer of an api have to decide maybe
it's better to have a beautifully
crafted runtime error than to have an
extremely obtuse compile-time error but
at the very least it does make sure that
the error is caught you're guaranteed
not to encounter this problem at runtime
that's part of the trade-off you're
making
all right
and so for my last trick
i would like to talk about a really key
problem so let's say we have extend this
with the ability to customize the
delimiters
so we're going to add a pair of
characters
that by default will be the square
brackets
and then we'll print out those square
brackets down here at this point in the
talk i also apologize these are
cross-cutting changes that will require
going across the code so this is going
to get a little complicated but i'll try
and review the code after i make each
big change to make sure we understand
what's going on
so i'll add those delimiters to the
print
and now
oh oh right i still have this
compile failure
now i have this basic square brackets
thing
and then we want to add a method that's
going to let us change these delimiters
so impul iter progress enter
pub function with delimiters that takes
a self and delimiters as a pair of
characters
return self and then sets self.delimit
equals to delims just like the bound
thing
and then return self
so if we call this let's make some
delimiters we can say let brackets
equals angle brackets
and then dot
progress.withbound.withdlims
brackets
if we call this
now we get our
customized progress bar with a nice
little different visual display
but
if we try and call this on our unbounded
iterator so if i say zero dot dot dot
progress dot with the limbs
brackets
what happens
i don't see any change in the output
again calling back to the error we saw
with tqdm
and so this might be confusing for a
user i tried to configure something i
thought would make a difference but i
didn't see any difference in the output
why
and the core issue is that progress is
now a stateful object based on whether
or not it is in the bounded or unbounded
state
and
these methods the with the limbs method
is allowed to be called regardless of
which state you're in
so let's change that i'm going to show
you a particularly advanced technique
called type state where we encode the
state of the a progress bar in the type
system
to do that first we need to each each
state so we have an unbounded state
and a bounded state that has a bound as
a use size or a set of delimiters as a
pair of characters
then we are going to add a type
parameter to progress of the bound and
that's what's going to sit in this bound
field
excuse me
then we need something that ties these
two data structures together of course
it is a trait
progress display we will call it that
will print out something to the screen
function display
takes as input a pointer to self and
then the progress bar
i'm going to lightning speed here so
apologize for any mistakes and then
we're going to implement this trait
impul progress display for both types
unbounded
which is going to have this type
signature
and then we'll also implement this
for the bounded type
and the implementation is just going to
move the code that we had in our match
statement
down here we're going to move that up
here
so now if it's bounded we'll call this
print statement
and just update our fields as necessary
so instead of self.i this becomes
progress.i
and becomes self.bound
and then this print gets put up here
which again becomes progress.i
make sure we add the appropriate markers
so we don't get a syntax error
all right
so now we have this trait implemented
for both of our states the common
functionality
now we have to refactor the rest of our
code so instead of referring to progress
we have to refer now to the additional
state we added to progress so initially
progress will be unbounded so that's the
initial state bound is unbounded
and then the other key thing is when we
call with bound this will change the
type of the progress bar that's the key
aspect of type state
when we are in the unbounded state and
you have an exact size iterator you can
call with bound that does not return
self but it returns progress of it or
comma bounded
so we'll say let bound equals to bounded
of bound is self.iter.len
and then the dilems are by default our
pair of brackets
and then we will return a distinct
structure a new type i self.i itter
self.itter and then the bound
and then finally the withdelims method
is only implemented for the bounded
state
and so we can only call this
self.bounds.delims
when we know that bounded is the type
bounded is the thing inside of our
progress data structure
all right we gotta keep going a lot of
changes to make next we have to change
our iterator which works for both bounds
so that becomes a type parameter and
then we'll say bound implements progress
display
and then self.bound.display
and self
good
last thing is the
trait we added also returns the
constructor which is unbounded by
default
let's see if it compiles
oh
it may not compile oh i think uh
oh i almost forgot one thing this also
needs to be sized
don't worry about why
clear cargo run dash cue
oh no i missed something
all right we're going to figure this out
oh do i define unbounded twice
you mean uh implement display for
unbounded and bounded
i see oh oh thank you wow i have such a
good audience
oh my god
wow okay props to you thank you thank
you
[Applause]
in my moment of need
the audience came through all right well
clearly you got it great
props to all of you um so that's pretty
cool wow we did it and importantly the
api down here didn't change
but instead or now what happens let me
change the code first
if i change this for loop
and instead of if i try to say dot
progress dot with the limbs previously
this was a valid api call
but now if i try and compile this
i'll get out an error that says no
method named with the limbs found for
struct progress unbounded and then down
here in the note it says this method was
found for progress it or comma bounded
so that's cool that's type state we've
taken whether or not we're in a bounded
state turned that into a type these two
distinct structs and then made it a type
parameter so that we can change the type
as we transition through our state
machine this is actually a really cool
technique that's used in other apis if
you've ever heard of the rocket web
server they have something similar for
the different stages of starting up a
web server embedded computing libraries
will use this to represent like the
state of your pins on your arduino or
something like that your raspberry pi
and so this is a neat way to
again help the user catch mistakes with
a state machine so for example with
bound must be called before with
delimiters and then rather than being a
comment in your documentation this is
enforced by the compiler that's what it
means to have type driven api design
okay that's all the cool stuff i have
time for i'm sure you have other
questions or maybe comparisons to other
languages and i'm happy to take your
questions offline but just to reiterate
what we saw today so the main idea is
traits traits are the foundational unit
by which you organize an api they define
an interface and then you can implement
those traits for types but in rust and
this is also true for haskell in other
type or type class or trait-based
languages you have this flexibility to
implement traits for types that you
don't own you have this flexibility to
be parametric over these interfaces and
you can combine these where clauses in
really creative ways to help users avoid
mistakes to make sure you can only call
a method when certain capabilities exist
or to or when your object is in a
certain state for example that's what we
saw with type state
and so these are all instances of api
design that i've seen and different rust
apis that i've used and hopefully this
has distilled them down into a slightly
simpler more pedagogic form where you
can really get a sense of how these
evolve rather than just seeing the
individual instances of apis
yeah that's about it thank you for
listening
[Music]
[Applause]
you